ça va
marc vallée
ça pour votre fils c'est tout comme
j'espère que ça va lui plaire ça fait
deux ans que les palus
à l'arrivée de m
je suis sûr qu'ils avaient pas menti
ce qu'il faut c'est sûr bonnet l'atome
me demander à l'autre non non c'est un
sale type e mail un avion city l'autre
c'est quoi ça c'est un chien c'est par
un chien c'est un ours ça maintenant
dans tout l'attachement du sb20 mills a
disparu il ya deux jours vous êtes le
seul à pouvoir posséder
l'avarice mourges riecherts angelino
êtes passé trop vite
non mais je rêve
ton père et j'ai pas peur on va y aller
jusqu'à stationné aux anges
et à partir de maintenant c'est moi qui
commande c'est clair
et qui est un manga brienne son occupant
avec les pompiers si sûr qu'ils ont
démarré lundi
personne peut aller là bas c'est trop
dangereux
c'est là qu'il fallait pas tous qu'une
chose c'est trop petit pour comprendre
jamais été minimes filles moi qui tu as
dit qu'on était ami
les pièges à la clé y à partir de
maintenant c'est moi qui commande
sigler